donald trump came out hot
from his deposition yesterday with new
york attorney general leticia james
trump pleaded the fifth more than 400
times despite previously claiming only
the mob and guilty people plead the
fifth and then he spent the day
absolutely losing it on his platform
truth social
take a look at what the president spent
the afternoon doing first of all
posting all sorts of different videos
attacking leticia james
and uh
attack videos of different kinds
then saying at the very plush beautiful
and expensive attorney general's office
nice working conditions as people are
being murdered all over new york and she
spends her time and effort on trying to
get trump
trump then continuing and posting this
entire statement about how leticia james
campaigned on getting trump and she's a
racist and she's hostile and she's just
determined to go after him a multi-page
tirade
uh that makes uh absolutely no sense if
you've been following the facts of the
investigation
trump then continuing about the raid
saying
he participated and it was a surprise
attack and it was all without warning or
notification
trump then sang
just leaving the attorney general's
office a very professional meeting
having a fantastic company with great
assets
very little debt and lots of cash only
in america even that doesn't appear to
be true at this point about donald
trump's businesses trump then posting a
picture of a police car outside
mar-a-lago
with an article from the new york post
posting that in fact multiple times just
spending his entire day posting all of
this stuff
and he wants all of us to believe things
that are simply unbelievable and not
true trump wants us to believe that
because he was participating in
conversations with the fbi
that the search warrant must have been
illegal or immoral
in fact legal experts have pointed out
oh no no no the fact that trump was in
contact with the fbi and they still
issued a search warrant suggests that
trump was not actually providing to the
fbi what he was supposed to provide it's
it's not better doesn't look better for
trump that the warrant was served after
he was speaking to them it actually
looks worse donald trump wants us to
believe that him even being deposed by
letitia james is some horrible act of
unfairness and injustice and whatever
else the case may be this is a guy who
has spent five years
using every legal mechanism he could
think of to avoid releasing his taxes to
anyone including the house including
anybody despite claiming as soon as his
audits were over he would release them
who has spent the time avoiding having
to be deposed in sexual assault
allegation cases multiple of them which
i have told you about trying to avoid
providing all sorts of records to all
sorts of different agencies who has
tried to avoid being deposed by letitia
james on every single one of these
donald trump has gone above and beyond
what any normal person would be allowed
to get away with or could afford to get
away with and so with all the people who
have now come out of the woodwork from
the right saying you know we've got to
be really worried trump's deposition
the search warrant at mar-a-lago
if it could happen to trump it could
happen to any of us it happens to all of
us all the time we're we the the
two-tiered justice system is very clear
and we deal with this stuff all the time
it's the trumps of the world that often
don't have to deal with it and it's
absolutely stunning that now they are
pulling all of this so donald trump
clearly with much free time to just post
and post and post to truth social and
the next question becomes what is the
next step and i know that you know think
about matt gates we learned about the
matt gates child sex traffic
investigation in march of 2021
nothing has really happened yet
these things can take a long time and i
know that there are many of you anxious
to see well what's the next thing what's
leticia james going to do what's the doj
going to do after the search warrant at
mar-a-lago will it happen this week next
week the next week after that
maybe
but this stuff can take months if not
years
so my suggestion is
let's take it a day at a time right now
the focus really should be the 2022
midterms we can't do anything about the
timing of these investigations into
trump
we actually can do something in november
which is voting and that means down
ballot and that means in every race
available for you to vote in that should
be the focus we will take a quick break
if you want to look at some of these
clips and posts find them on our
instagram at david pakman show we're
going to be back very very soon
one of our sponsors today is bluechu a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping